>>Narrator: Clarence Wells spends two
days a week rebuilding racing cars.
Evelyn Sanchez spends her
Tuesdays and Thursdays working
at a veterinary hospital.
And Chandelle Wilson helps
run a non-profit arts center.
These aren't part-time, afterschool
jobs, but school day internships
that allow students to
pursue their own passions
in real-world learning situations.
>>Chandelle: If we apply for 75, what
exactly can we get done with that?
>>Narrator: The internship
program is just part
of a unique high school concept
launched in 1997 in Providence,
Rhode Island at a school
called The Met.
>>Dennis: You just think
about how people learn.
They learn when they love something.
They learn when they have a passion,
when they're interested in something.
They learn-- subjects
aren't broken down.
You kind of think of home schooling.
If you're home schooling your
kid, you wouldn't put them
in a living room for 45 minutes
and then ring a bell and move them
to the kitchen and study science
for 45 minutes, and ring a bell.
You'd have them meet great people,
read great books, do real stuff,
and so that's how we said let's
see if we can create a school.
>>Chandelle: The word "passion,"
you know, like finding your passion.
I've never even heard of
it until I came to The Met.
I'd be like, "And what
are you talking about?"
>>You're crazy, like, I
don't know, I'm fourteen.
So I didn't really
know what to expect.
I think everything kind
of happened accidentally.
>>Oh, look at the red cardinals.
>>Narrator: For Chandelle,
the happy accidents began
when she met her first mentor,
photographer Therese Grente.
>>Chandelle: I-- she
had a 35 millimeter.
>>Therese: Okay.
>>Chandelle: My best experiences were
when I found someone who was able
to have enough time to work with me
instead of just giving me work to do.
When I was with Therese,
it was great.
When I had a question, it
was her that I went back to.
It wasn't someone else.
>>Therese: Kind of tell, so you'll
visually start seeing all that,
like with the negative.
>>Chandelle: We had good times, we
were able to talk to each other.
It's just very personal.
>>Charles: So how far
have you gotten so far?
So let's say..
>>Narrator: The Met's personalized
learning philosophy begins
with its size.
It accommodates just 150 students
who spend two days working
at their internships,
and the other school days
in a small advisory group at school.
Fifteen students work
with one teacher,
who helps them create
individual learning plans
and supervises their
independent studies
over the course of four years.
>>Charles: Now is there a
conclusion of some sort?
>>I've gotten to know
each one of them,
each one of their learning styles,
their family situations,
how they tick.
I know when they're
turned on to something,
when something's going on with them.
It becomes sort of a family, and
they all refer to our advisory here
as some sort of semi-dysfunctional
family,
but everyone cares about each other.
>>You were doing the same
shot at different exposures.
>>Chandelle: Yep.
>>Charles: Okay.
>>Chandelle: It's called equal
exposure depth of field stuff.
>>I think having a
relationship like that
with your teacher definitely helps.
It helps me learn because
I can ask him a question.
"You know, I don't understand
this, please explain it to me,"
without feeling embarrassed
or scared.
>>And this one's of my
brother floating in a pond.
It was another spur
of the moment thing.
>>Narrator: There are no
tests or letter grades here.
Instead, students study core academic
subjects by conducting research..
>>Student: I talked to some
people up at Brown University..
>>Narrator: ...completing
projects and giving presentation
to their parents, mentors, and
students in thier advisory.
>>Charles: By the time they apply
to college they've had 12
exhibitions, 13 exhibitions.
They're amazing presenters.
>>Chandelle: You can use your
fingers in the water to work it off
of the paper backing here.
>>Charles: They blow
people away at interviews,
they have portfolios,
they have resumes.
They have a way to show the
quality work that they've done.
>>Chandelle: But here you have
a Polaroid emulsion transfer.
>>Narrator: The Met claims an
impressive graduation rate,
especially for a population
of at-risk students,
90 percent of whom go on to college.
So The Met concept has spread
beyond Providence to more
than a dozen other
cities including Oakland,
California where Evelyn Sanchez
interns at a local veterinary clinic.
>>Evelyn: I really like being
here on Tuesdays and Thursdays.
I even come on the
weekends and I get paid.
I want to pursue veterinary
in the future,
hopefully when I get
out of high school.
>>Okay. Turn on the
anaesthesia machine.
>>I would love to go to UC Davis.
I know that it's a very
competitive school,
but that's what I want
to do in the future.
I want to hopefully become a doctor.
>>Elena: Good boy;
So we'll let him soak
and then we're going
to go do the neuter.
Push him toward the wall.
>>Evelyn: Okay.
>>Elena: In high school, you know,
what were you going to
do when you grow up?
Who knows?
You know, I think it's better for
the kids because they have more
of a track to follow, and she knows
now that you have to keep your grades
up from ninth grade
on, even before that.
They don't just look at your
last year, where when we were
in high school it was more like
oh just goof off and do whatever,
and then towards the end, pick it up.
>>Narrator: At an East Oakland body
shop, Clarence Wells is studying math
and science while rebuilding
racing cars.
>>Clarence: I've learned
a lot about cars,
like how math relates
to real-world stuff.
I've been taking a physics
class, and that's tied in a lot
with the stuff I do here.
I wrote a paper about,
like, aerodynamics
and I'm learning a lot
of stuff about that.
My logic's getting better, and like,
being able to analyze
something and solve problems.
Also what's important is how fast
and efficient I can do stuff,
so like I think about that more
and I'm like, doing homework.
Like what's the most efficient
way I can get this done?
>>Narrators: Mentors like Dan and
Karen Gallant believe the value
of Met internships goes well
beyond the work that's done.
>>Karen: There are so many
people that are adrift,
and the schools don't have any
money for a lot of programs.
They certainly don't have any
money for vocational programs,
as you've probably heard.
And I think this gives them a chance
to learn different skills and also
to learn what they might really
want to pursue as a career.
>>Chiem: I'm still learning, so
that's one of the good things.
Being at Met West is good.
They gave me opportunity to come
here and pursue my dreams and stuff.
>>Daniel: They're having
to learn to be responsible
for things they wouldn't normally be
responsible for until they got a job.
And we're not whip-crackers
or anything like that,
but we do have a fairly high
standard that we want things done to.
>>Narrator: While Met West's
curriculum is anything but standard,
the school measures up
on standardized tests.
>>Matt: We don't do
a lot of test prep,
but we do take the
tests very seriously.
Our seniors have the
highest pass rate
on the California High School Exit
Exam in both English and math,
for all schools in Oakland unified.
And I think part of this is
because we are a small school,
we know our students well.
We know what they do well, and we
know what they need improvement on,
and we're able to tailor
some individual curriculum
to meet those needs.
>>Charles: I watch them find this
passion and develop from these angry,
young kids to these
positive, socially conscious,
academically high-achieving
kids who are doing things not
because I tell them to do it, but
because they are just hungry for it.
>>Narrator: For more
information on what works
in public education,
go to Edutopia.org